so many people love the show Silicon
Valley but what's fascinating to me is
it one of your biggest fans is none
other than Bill Gates Bill Gates
publicly said said most of popular
culture is always trying to get Silicon
Valley and try and capture the essence
of it and he said no show has gotten it
right until Silicon Valley was I thought
must have blown your mind yeah yeah this
may come as a shock to you but I'm a big
fan of Windows NT 95 whatever are you uh
are you seriously are you a tech guy and
yeah I mean look I'm a gamer so like
Windows is a part of it but uh no when
someone said hey he wrote this article
is like Oh like Bill Gates trashes
Silicon Valley but it was essentially
like a really flattering review yeah
dude you of just like this gets it right
and at the character identify most of
most with his own Richard Hendricks yeah
yeah he said he identified the most of
your character and then he tweeted out
this photo where he took a photo of
himself and then he put your face on his
body from back in the day I thought that
was that's I mean no that's real he sent
that out apparently he memed it yeah he
did he means yeah Bill Gates me yeah
yeah
very honored and I'm happy he used such
a flattering photo